oh oh non non non on insiste pas
hippolyte u ne chantera pas ce soir à la
fête annuelle du port et pourquoi et
pourquoi vous sait très bien que je
chante très bien j'ai une très jolie
voix et en plus je chante juste dallas
arrête de dire des bêtises et passez moi
plutôt le poivre toujours moi qui fais
la bonne il est là voilà pourquoi n'y a
aucune raison que je ne chante pas à la
fête du port d'ailleurs tiens écoute on
va c'est joli bravo hein comme un
chanteur de charme qui aura bonne mine
j'aurais l'ami qu'il plaît je suis
complètement en web un plan pour écoute
il vaut mieux être un peu enrouée
maintenant ici que ce soir avec l'air du
large
tu t'imagines si tu perdes est à voir en
plein milieu du spectacle
je chanterai qu'à moi même voilà
non tu ne chantera pas si non ci est
bien bien que se passe t'il encore ici
tous les deux casimir ne peut pas que je
chante à la fête du port
j'ai rien compris qu est ce que tu as
dit kazim et r2 par jean bazerque pas tu
tu comprend quelque chose à ce qu'il
raconte peut chanter ce soir à la fête
annuelle du par avec cette voix là mon
bras d'honneur
c'est ce que je me tue à lui répété
depuis une piaget fallu un tir à
khouribga et moi ah ben non pas surtout
pas dans ces très mauvais pour la voix
ça a tant pis alors adieu ruby boulga je
préfère chanter oui mais qu'est ce que
vous racontez tous les deux en fin de le
programme de la fête est établi depuis
longtemps
c'est marie chanson qui doit chanter par
hippolyte
elle ne peut pas venir qu'est ce qu'il
dit il dit comme marie chanson ne
viendra pas chanter ce soir
le rédacteur en chef de son journal l'a
envoyé sur un reportage a et b
évidemment c'était le risque
les journalistes doivent toujours être
prêt à partir dès qu'il se passe un
événement important quelque part ça
c'est d'autant plus dommage qu elle
devait chanter une chanson qui
casimir mon ami et cette chanson parle
de moi mouvaux casimir tu pourrais être
un peu plus modeste
il sera modeste calculé casimir se
rendait dans un vraiment je ne comprends
pas un bout de ce qu'il raconte
tu devrais nous le mime et la wii u masi
mime sociale les les nuages les nuages
tu crois le jour le jour le jour le jour
oui le jour quoi les casimir je sais que
le jour où les casimir l'usiné rue st le
jour où les caisses tu es complètement
fou beth ditto
heureusement que t'as pas de deux au
stade ias j'ai trouvé oui il voulait
dire le jour où les casimir russes ont
aidé en arabe
il y avait quand même d'autres façons mi
mai saint hippolyte non mais dis moi à
propos de quoi disait tu ça au fait à
propos de ta modestie désigné oui oui
selon la police tu seras modeste le joug
voulait casimir us auront des dents quoi
comment je me suis pour modeste mois le
plus mauvais de tous les mandats ça
passait pas moi qui suis méchante ou
casimir casimir pour calme toi s'il te
plaît calme toi je suis très calme bon
hippolyte fais comme tu veux mais je
crois qu'avec cette voie là personne ne
t'entendra enfin il se dirige tout droit
vers la maison de monsieur beauchamp je
crois qu'il prépare quelque chose si tu
as raison casimir suivant la distance
quand j'ai commencé commencer bon voila
voila ça vient ça vient du mot chaîne
peut dit-il
je ne sais pas il est 13 ans oui bien tu
me donnes tu peux plein pourquoi tu fais
ce que tu chantes ample et battez vous
aimez c'est pour faire la danse a un ça
va mieux que bien
mesdames et messieurs quel bois je vais
bout qu'il offre dans la salle
je vais vous interpréter avec ma belle
voix c'est sûrement une voie de garage
ou une voix de ce mode vous là bas et le
gros ange silence s'il vous plaît
laissez travailler l'artiste d'avoir il
ya un artiste 10,6 pouces à sillas vais
bien je vais vous interpréter avec ma
belle voix et par le geste mais aussi
par la voix ou plutôt par la voix mais
aussi par le jette enfin ligue 2 quoi je
vous ai pas prêté ma première chanson
lui ville
[Applaudissements]
je me lève le soleil c'est ma peau rosée
du genre dans un élan qui me soulève je
m'habille départ sur les chemins de la
marche à pied
les matin au saut du lit je pars en
chantonne la marche à pied quelle
merveille
le bonheur on le trouve
chan ah bravo à vous plaît vraiment pour
ce que touche en aucun cas les yeux
devant d'imitateur oh oui qu'est ce
qu'ils pensent que c'est simple je sais
pas ce qui s'est passé je t'assure j'ai
su plus rien bon allez on fait attention
voilà prochaine bien après ces petits
prologue humoristique
voici ma deuxième chanson vas-y
[Musique]
j'ai chassé les dameurs pendant trois
jours au con j'ai jouer à saute pas loin
avec la chasse
je suis très cela chaque jeu god on
creuse un petit rush à moi petit et
jamais j'ai chanté
opéra dans l'or
cocteau trouver les trésors un
cadencement
les gens sachent mai
on a
connu dans un heurt
en quartiers
je
suis un champion de la sculpture
fait lâcher de faisans peinture je suis
le plus grand
qu'est ce qui t'arrive tu dis il a
vraiment un don de 1000 est formidable
c'est vraiment n'importe quoi on sait ce
que je peux ballet musique un euro
shaft
comme un corner est terminée fatigué je
pars mort posée
mais si sous la main sans refrain plein
d'entrain je ne peux résister si c'était
vrai qu'une jama mais le patient pour
une mazurka il faut que j'aille danser
tous les parlements ressemblera
longtemps de secret pour moi donc c'est
simon bonnet même si chanteur puisque
c'est ça jara pas pourquoi tu veux bien
tout le monde adore ton numéro
d'imitateur tu crois et bien sûr c'est
vrai le maire composent non j'avoue j'ai
appelé mes amis oui oui oui l'axé
naughty bear limitation je vous l'avais
bien cachons